so Malaysia what was it like having a
u.s. senator teach class it was very
enlightening because I'm very interested
in politics and I watched the news a lot
so to have somebody who works in
politics and works related to the
president for me to talk to him and ask
some questions it was it was really fun
I thought it was a great experience
being with the senator in a classroom I
would never expect that but I think that
this experience would be great for me
for me want to go to law school and yeah
just think it's a great experience for
us in eighth grade to be with the
senator in a classroom and Sophia did
was it what you would would expect from
a senator it was not he was really good
at it I mean you were expecting him not
to be good not necessarily but he was
like it felt like he belonged in the
classroom and why was that well I mean
he was like he was just teaching like a
teacher you know some people get up
there and they're just talking but he
was like telling us almost like it was a
story yeah what did you think though I
thought it was really an amazing
experience and like to be talking to him
a real-life senator like this guy this
is his job like he's working up there
with some of these really big guys in
the name of politics and he is his own
like Senator John Kennedy like that's a
big name for us in Louisiana and so it
was really neat to be able to see him
like in the flesh and to talk to him I
shook his hand like that's just an
amazing experience to me emily's you
said you're really interested in
politics what what interests you about
politics do you want to go into politics
well for most of my life for all my life
really I've went to be a doctor and I
still want to be a pediatric oncologist
but politics has kind of been like a
hobby for me ever since I was young my
dad has always watched the news with me
so it's kind of like a family thing and
yeah so it's just something I something
I do and what if you had to describe
politics right now what would you say
about it very divisive it's a very tense
time in America period
that's probably why I'm so interested
maybe sometimes I feel like I can do
something about it
senator Kennedy went to to law schools
so he was a lawyer and then became one
into politics would you want to go into
politics I really want to graduate from
UGA and then go to Senate law school and
then I want to become a judge for either
in Louisiana or Georgia or I want to be
a governor one day so I'm debating but
it's half and half I'm not sure yet sure
well you've got a few days I probably
have you by this weekend yeah very
focused you seem extremely focused what
do you want to do I want to be a
cultural anthropologist thank you is a
particular period of time or you know I
really like learning about the ancient
Greeks Romans that kind of time period
because once we get more recent I don't
know it just kind of seems a little bit
boring and so also yeah I'd like to
travel the world and I think that's a
great field to do it so the idea is you
were talking about in class today a lot
of those come from the Greeks and the
Romans who started out thinking about
how you form a government and why you
form a government and who you give the
ideas to is that would interest you or
does what interest you just the way they
live their lives and you know I'm really
interested in like a lot of the things
they were doing that was the first that
anyone had ever done that and I think
that's really interesting and scary and
it's like and also I'm interested in
like the art because they did do a lot
of art the sculptures and stuff and so
yeah I think just in general that time
period is really interesting and what
about you would you ever want to go to
Washington and be in government probably
not for me I'd like to be a biologist
when I grew up probably either an
entomologist so studying insects or some
sort of herpetologists like I love
salamanders I
being out in the mountains and like with
streams and so salamanders seems like a
really good species or like an animal to
be studying to get to do all that cool
field work and I'm partly influenced cuz
I come from a big family of biologists
so my dad studies plants
my mom says parrots my grandfather study
spiders my grandmother's studies wasps
oh yeah a lot of a lot of biologists in
the family Malaysia what makes a good
teacher and was the senator a good
teacher and if so what makes him good I
think a main quality that every teacher
should have is to not get frustrated
when students acts a lot questions like
Sophie I can tell you I ask the most
questions every day yeah so I think page
features need to be patient with their
students and I think mr. Kennedy was
pretty patient and you asked him a
question about whether one party was in
control of all branches of government
where did that question come from the
current branches of government I mean
it's the Republicans do you have control
of the legislative legislative branch
and the executive branch and members of
their party had the majority at the
Supreme Court so I was just you know
axing him because it came to my mind
when he was talking about the branches
but yeah and he said that the Supreme
Court is supposed to be political yeah
great to think of that I agree with him
when he says it's not supposed to be
political I think it is political it's
not supposed to be but I think that the
majority of the Supreme Court will vote
with Republican ideals because
Republicans do have a majority in the
Supreme Court so I think that they
should vote fairly and be bipartisan
about it but I don't think it will
happen Sophia when you have a class like
this and you talk about the beginnings
of American government the way it's
supposed to work the three branches of
government the three levels of
government does that feel like you're
having a conversation about something
that is ancient and started at the
founding of America or that's exactly
the way things work today
you know it's I think that what you say
ancient I would say that the starting of
America wasn't that long ago
sure well because you're a cultural
anthropologist but nevertheless was it
is it something that's happening today
or happened 230 I think it's it's
definitely something that happens today
and you see it all the time and when you
listen to the news and it's like oh yeah
he's talking about 200 years ago but
he's also talking about now trading you
there was a lot of questions at the
senator pose that were just kind of
trying to get your your ideas about gosh
everything from assisted suicide to the
Palestinian Liberation Organization was
that fun trying to figure out how
government works instead just facts and
being talked at yes I did feel like it
was interesting number one from hearing
it from him in our class and kids
interacting with him and having a
discussion to see how the government
works and see the behind the scenes of
the government Dylan are you hopeful do
you feel like they know what they're
doing in Washington I mean I have a lot
of faith in those guys that's their job
so I sure do hope that they're doing all
they can to you know protect us as
Americans and and do their job right
does your feeling like yeah this is all
you know working the way it's supposed
to the way we talk about it in school
it's all smooth running just the way
they designed it or no not at all I mean
I don't want to sound political but you
know our president is using a lot of
racist rhetoric rhetoric and talking
about certain people or certain groups
of people as if he's trying to scare a
part of America and it does scare me
sometimes that this is our president the
leader of the free world talking about
people sometimes Americans and this way
so it's it's definitely not normal but I
think that we've accepted it as normal
and I think that's why I'm so scared
sometimes when I watch politics so yeah
I definitely don't feel okay when I
watch but you are still really
interested in it and want to be involved
in it right that's probably why I want
to be involved in it because of how much
it's how much it's affected me and how I
feel every day really so that's why
sometimes I feel like I want to make a
difference in politics and I actually
have a cousin who is a state senator
Regina Barrow and I went to the Capitol
and I worked with her and helped helped
around so that was pretty fun and
interesting getting to meet different
people who work there in the Capitol and
that definitely interested me something
I might want to do Sofia today do you
talk about politics at home yeah but
it's not something that enthralls me
quite as much as Malaysia you know I
think it's important for me too and I
think at some times I'm not I'm not
invested in it as much as I should be
because I'm a citizen but I think I'm 13
years old I have a little bit of time
before I need to start worrying about
these things mostly because it is
something that I worry about but I don't
follow it as closely as maybe I should
you said there you're a citizen there's
a lot of talk about who is a citizen and
who isn't what does it mean to be a
citizen you know I think it means to
love your country to support it no
matter what and to you know do your
duties like voting following the law you
know stuff like that today one of the
things that a number of and you may have
said it too a lot of times in class when
the senator would would say well what if
we did this a lot of people said would
be really controversial which I thought
was an interesting word that people kept
using a lot do you feel like there's a
lot of controversy and in politics right
now is it yes I do feel like it's a lot
because many people have different
opinions
to me politics is opinions just
different point of views such as a
Republican and Democrat those are two
different opinions because you may like
the Republican or you may like the
Democrat candidate so yes I do feel like
it's opinionated you know where do you
do you know where your politics are no
but um I do agree with Democrats yeah
the Democratic Party and is politics
something you talk about at home no I
really don't really discuss politics
with my family because they're not that
interested but whenever we do talk about
politics I mainly talk about it in class
and my social study class and I mainly
catch up with seeing intent so that's
what I'm going to talk about politics
yeah is this one of your is this a class
you like or it's science and biology
more something you're you know I I do
love science class don't get me wrong
but yeah at this ever since I came to
the school I've just absolutely loved
history and social studies I mean in
sixth grade I had an amazing history
teacher mr. wall and so yeah it's
definitely made me a lot more interested
in social studies and it's just made a
lot more fun for me yeah why is that is
it because it's like a story is that
like yours I think that's exactly right
and to learn like how people live back
then and then also more into like social
studies and government how stuff works
now to kind of get that behind the
scenes yeah that's all really really
exciting to me Sophia have you ever I
know you like to watch YouTube
occasionally have you ever sought out
something to watch that was either about
you know the early days of Greece in
Rome or about the origins of American
history something you've learned in
class that then has led you to go seek
out information on your own you know
yeah I wouldn't say on YouTube more just
on the Internet in general occasionally
you know we have really good history
teachers here at McKinley like Dylan
said and I think that sometimes
something will really grasp my attention
that I'd like to look further into
but yeah I like to keep my YouTube
separate from my schoolwork sure
Malaysian you said you that the
president made you feel scared or the
currents say things made you feel scared
do you Senator Kennedy is obviously a
Republican is a supporter of the
president's did how did you feel about
those feelings you have about government
after happens spending 90 minutes with
him um well I'm not necessarily against
Republicans it's just that for the
people who won't stand up to Trump who
had that position such as being a
senator or representative whether
democrat or republican if you don't send
up to Trump I think that's a problem so
I mean I was asking senator Kennedy
about what he thought about things that
President Trump has said and I mean I
don't I don't think it's he's a bad guy
he's pretty nice the senator you mean
Trey what would you like the senator to
know that you might not have gotten a
chance to tell him one thing that I
would like for him to know that he did
an amazing job with substituting with us
and I hope he can do better and change
what's going on in this world and that
Louisiana could be great and Dylan what
were you expecting were you thinking
like senator yeah I guess I didn't
really know what to expect going into
this I was kind of thinking I was I was
pretty nervous I was like what are we
gonna do I didn't know what this man
like substitute teacher but in the end I
was I was really happy with what we did
I mean getting to talk with him about
like all these issues and getting to
discuss and which is the thing that he
does regularly with his job so yeah it
was it was really interesting what would
you want him to know so Kay quit
politics you have a talent go teach
preferably here yeah I think you did a
really good job
it I was interested in government and
politics and I think that he he had he
was really good at just talking with us
like sparking our interest in what's
what's going on here and what do you
think about this and sometimes he even
changed my opinion about something
oh yeah like what like the motorcycle
thing with the helmets he was saying
well maybe that's you should be able to
not wear a helmet because I mean it's
it's your life and that just got me
thinking and I'm not really sure where I
stand on that anymore because at first I
was like yeah you should wear a helmet
like that's your safety you should be
protected but now I'm thinking well it's
not hurting other people Trey do you go
talk about politics with your friends or
at school no they have no idea what
politics is probably but if I was to
have a pilot like a pilot take
discussion I probably have a whip
Malaysia because Malaysia is like very
like interested in that and I would like
to know more than what I know now yeah
do you talk politics with your friends
like I do I do
usually I might bring up a topic and
social studies class just for fun and do
people there's a lot of talk about
civility in public and American public
life right now and things getting tense
tense and do you guys feel that do you
feel that things are tense in public
life in America right now
what do you think about that well I
think that I think we should all
remember that we're all human beings we
all have feelings and that our opinions
shouldn't necessarily divide us so much
maybe we should stop shouting at each
other and maybe you know talk to each
other just because somebody has one
opinion doesn't mean that they can't be
your friends and that they're not nice
people and that's what we learned today
with this talk with Senator Kennedy he's
a really nice guy that no matter what
your political opinions are yak Sophia
earlier what she thinks being a citizen
is and I think to be a citizen I think
being a citizen means that you want the
best for your country
maybe not well not necessarily to raise
your status but to help the people below
you hope the people that don't have as
many advantages as as you have and I
think basically being a citizen needs to
be a brother/sister to your neighbor
what if you went home and said or they
or someone asked you what happened in
school today what would you say I would
tell them about how we learned how the
government works and federal other
levels federal state and local and then
I would tell them that I've learned how
to like it's okay for people to have
different opinions and from to hear from
a Republican and like the stereos of a
Republican I saw that it's very
different and Republicans are not the
same I was hoping that I talked to a
u.s. senator that he brought a news
station to her to my school that I
talked about the government and the
different rights that we as citizens
have and just having different views of
what it means to be a citizen and what
it means to have certain rights and the
rights that we are given
I would say that we learned about you
know the the separation of powers
between the national and state
governments we talked a lot about that
about how there are certain powers that
are given to the national government but
the state still holds the states still
hold power as well so it's not just like
the federal government has taken all the
power and then as tre said I also
learned that you know opinions don't
define who a person is they can still
just just as well be your friends so I
think that I would say I learned that
freedom of religion and expression and
speech and just freedom in general it's
so complicated and it's not just making
laws it's not just this clean-cut thing
like in the Constitution that says this
so we have to do this because there's so
many different things and you could
argue I can honestly argue for both
sides and a lot of these things that he
asked us about that's right it's the
implied powers where it gets really
sticky you know well thank you all so
much this was really great for me